-Welcome back. We're here
with Senator Bernie Sanders.
You were with President Biden
at his inauguration,
and you became a meme.
We've talked about you
and your mittens.
-Yeah.
-I'd heard you lost the mittens,
but then I realized -- not true.
-Not true. Fake news.
-Fake news. But there's a reason
we don't see the mittens.
-My wife is
hiding them away someplace.
-Yeah.
She worried you're getting
too involved in social media,
becoming a meme?
-[ Laughs ]
-So she's hid the mittens,
and that's why we don't see
the mittens.
-It's gonna be a legacy
for the grandchildren.
-Right. Those mittens
are going to be worth
a lot of scratch
when the time comes.
I know you have a lot
of immense personal respect
for President Biden.
Obviously, we have
an election coming up.
The Democratic voting coalition
is very diverse.
A lot of different kinds
of people.
Make a case for why
you think people should turn out
for President Biden in November.
-Well, for a first step,
it's absolutely imperative
that Donald Trump be defeated.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And it's -- let me, you know --
and what this election is about,
it is not just policy.
It's not just differences
of views on health care,
education, or tax policy.
You have a president,
former president,
who really does not believe
in democracy.
He's trying to
undermine democracy.
He is a pathological liar.
And he is,
in very intense ways,
trying to divide our people up.
Look, this country faces
enormous problems today,
and we all know what they are.
We're talking about income
and wealth inequality.
We're talking about
60% of workers
living paycheck to paycheck.
We're talking about
the existential
threat of climate change.
Enormous problems
facing this country.
But instead of focusing
and providing solutions
to those problems,
what Trump is trying to do
is get us to hate each other
based on where we were born,
or the color of our skin
or our sexual orientation,
and we just cannot
allow that to happen.
And then on top of all that,
you got a guy in Trump
who, during his presidency,
gave massive tax breaks
to the rich at a time
when we have unprecedented
income and wealth inequality.
It's the last thing they need.
This guy wants to throw
tens of millions of people
off of the health insurance
that they have.
He appointed anti-union
members of his administration
to make it harder
for workers to form unions.
And I'll tell you,
all over this country,
women are fighting for the right
to control their own bodies.
He wants to take that away.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So that's Trump.
And on the other hand,
in Biden --
I'm not going to sit here.
You know, I ran against Biden,
so I'm not going to sit here
and tell you that I agree with
everything Joe Biden is doing.
I don't, big time.
But on the other hand,
this is the first president in
the history of the United States
to walk on a picket line
with workers.
And that's a pretty
impressive thing.
We've made some progress
in lowering the cost
of prescription drugs
and taking on
the pharmaceutical industry.
The economy,
as you've indicated,
is really doing well.
Unemployment extremely low.
We're creating
a whole lot of jobs,
rebuilding manufacturing
in America.
So we're beginning to move
forward in the right direction.
In my view, we have a lot,
lot more to do.
But the choice in this election
is very clear.
If you do not believe
in democracy,
if you really want to turn
your back on the millions of men
and women
who fought to defend democracy,
I guess Trump is your candidate.
But if you believe in
what this country
is supposed to value,
is that we all come together
as one people,
we believe in the rule of law,
Biden is your candidate.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I want to ask,
because I know you've been
a voice in the Senate
over the current situation
in the Middle East.
We are almost four months
after the horrifically
unforgivable acts
of October 7th.
You've called Hamas a disgusting
terrorist organization.
Many hostages are not back.
And yet we also see
an unspeakable loss
of civilian lives in Gaza.
Is there --
Do you have any optimism for
a peaceful future for Israelis?
-I hope to God it takes place.
And as you've just indicated,
Hamas began this war
with their horrific,
brutal terrorist attack
against --
killing 1,200 innocent Israelis,
wounding more, taking over
200 people hostage.
But I have to tell you
that what Netanyahu
and his right wing government
are doing right now
to the people of Palestine
is -- of Gaza
is indescribable
and unspeakable.
I mean, we're looking at 25--
26,000 people who have been
killed already,
two-thirds of whom
are women and children,
65,000 people
who have been wounded.
We're looking at 70%
of the housing units in Gaza
have been damaged or destroyed.
Can you believe that?
70%? You're looking
at 1.8 million people
pushed out of their homes.
God knows where they're going.
And right now, and this is --
I hope everybody hears this.
You're looking
at the possibility
of hundreds of thousands
of children starving to death.
And we in the United States,
through our financial
support of Israel,
are complicit
in what's happening.
And I will be damned if I'm
going to give another nickel
to the Netanyahu government
in order to continue this war
against the Palestinian people.
-Do you see --
I mean, it all seems so, uh --
impossible --
I mean, I certainly don't know
the solution
I wouldn't ever claim to,
but do you see any hope
for optimism
that there's a future for the
Palestinians and the Israelis?
-The history
of the region is terrible.
You know, we don't have the time
to go into it.
Deals with the Holocaust,
6 million Jews.
It deals with the displacement
of hundreds of thousands
of Palestinians from their home.
But at the end of the day,
the people, Palestinian people
are entitled
to a homeland of their own.
So we're talking about
a two-state solution.
Hamas cannot be, in my view,
part of that equation.
They are a terrorist
jihadist group.
There are people, Palestinians,
who believe in democracy,
Palestinians who do believe
in improving the lives
of people there.
We've got to work
with those people
and create
a long term solution
where Israel has the security
that it is entitled to
and the Palestinians
have a state of their own
and the freedom
that they are entitled to.
-Well, we really appreciate
any time
you make time for us.
It is such a pleasure.
Thank you so much,
Senator Sanders.
-Thank you.
-Senator Bernie Sanders,
everybody.
"It's OK to be Angry
About Capitalism"
is in paperback
February 20th.
-We'll be right back
with Zosia Mamet.